at one point six trillion dollars in
student loan debt in America they the
average mortgage delinquency rate is 1.3
percent the average student loan
delinquency rate is 25 percent 1.3
percent of the mortgages are in default
25 percent of the student loans are in
default do you know why because you and
I are idiots we the taxpayers have
allowed our moronic Congress and federal
government to become the largest lender
of consumer debt in America today and we
have guaranteed these loans you and I
have guaranteed them the taxpayers
the federal government has guaranteed
the loans and if they're not repaid we
pick up the bill and 25 percent of their
men default do you know why because 18
year-olds want to move onto a college
campus and go $15,000 in debt to have
friends and you and I are making that
loan because Congress continues this
plague on America of this fire hose is
open of money loan to 18 year olds with
absolutely no guidelines you can take
out a student loan while you're in
college and go buy a car with the money
you can move onto a campus when you have
a perfectly good free education
available to you in your local community
college and nursing program and go
fifteen thousand dollars in debt and
then it doesn't work out
because you got married and there was a
car wreck and you had to take care of
him
your child is ill and you have to take
care of them and so that job you thought
you were going to do that was going to
justify this debt is gone because you
used an 18 year old 17 year old brain to
make the decision to borrow money to go
get friends this is why we have an epic
problem in America this is why we have a
plague in America and I'm not mad at
that dad he's doing a good job of
working with that little daughter of his
and he's trying to convince her and
persuade her and that's what we all do
with children as they grow if you want
them to grow up and leave they have to
have critical thinking skills so they
don't live in your basement till they're
40 and they develop critical thinking
skills by discussing it with them and
persuading them rather than just making
them do stuff if you just make them do
stuff you raise stuff for children who
don't have any skills at all on how to
live a life but when you teach them how
to live life and Waddle live life like
he's doing with her he's doing an
excellent job with that but this idea
that you and I are continuing to make
these loans and this is the
decision-making profile a lady young
lady called me from South Carolina she
wants to go to Mississippi to school
from South Carolina
now South Carolina has got in-state
tuition $8,000 a year or $11,000 a year
I'm sorry they've got in-state tuition
at Clemson's $14,000 a year and she
wants to go to Mississippi an
out-of-state tuition is $20,000 a year
so she's gonna pay six thousand dollars
more a year than she would pay at
Clemson nine thousand dollars more a
year than she would pay at South
Carolina and you know why she wanted to
go to Mississippi instead of the South
Carolina it was an in-state tuition and
going debt to do it by the way the
houses in the town are pretty
what on what planet would a banker lend
someone money that thinks like that no
planet except planet Congress no planet
would a banker that has half of a -
brain cells to rub together it says you
want to go into debt because the houses
look pretty instead of going to school
at home and paying cash for it
this isn't these are not people you loan
money to if you are a wise lender and
yet you and I have done it 1.6 trillion
times as taxpayers the federally insured
student loan program is an absolute epic
failure it is destroying people's lives
because we're financing stupidity at a
rate that is blinding and I'm not
talking about financing education we're
financing stupidity the houses are
pretty or I want friends is financing
stupidity and you and I are doing it
because your Congress continues to make
these loans and some of the left-winger
dingers are out there running around we
need to forgive all the student loans
and then them are talking about stopping
making them how can you talk about
forgiving them while you're still making
them
that's intellectual dishonesty that's
political hogwash guys this thing is a
mess it's an absolute mess and it's
going to cause economic problems
eventually because eventually I mean you
have a twenty five percent default rate
you understand if you're running a
business and your job was to be a lender
and you had a twenty five percent
default rate on one of your product
lines you would shut that sucker down
and call it a failure but you know what
the Department of Education is talking
about we're gonna separate the largest
lender said
came out this week said we're gonna talk
about separating the lending section
from the rest of the department of
education because the lending section is
one of the largest consumer lenders in
the world today why because we wanna
lend a little Sally so because the
houses are pretty and we're just dumber
than a rock we are because you keep
voting the morons in that keep this
program in place and no none of you have
called your Congressman and said stop
this you can start calling them today
call your senator it looks to me like
they need some distractions up there
they ain't got nothing to do so
seriously they need to stop this this is
asinine you guys you will loan a hundred
and forty five thousand dollars without
any collateral to an eighteen year old
on the hope that as an art major they're
gonna get a job and pay this crap back
you and I are stupid we are a horrible
bankers this is what socialism does this
is what stuff does it says I this is how
you work is how life works the
government takes it over it'll all be
better this is the DMV running a bank
that's what you got here
it's absolutely asinine and it's one of
the largest banks in the world and it's
got a 25 percent default rate and you
and I with our taxpayer dollars and the
debt they borrow in our name up there
are paying for this misbehavior guys
really is just stupid you want to know
more am I starting to tickle your anger
bone yeah well you need to get in touch
with your senator and your congressman
tell them to do something worthwhile
stop this crap pull the plug it is time
to end the federal insurance student
loan program it is an epic failure
it is a plague on America well it's a
children's we'll get to go to school yes
they will they can do a thing called get
a job
the average in-state tuition is $8,000 a
year ten thousand dollars a year that's
833 dollars a month you can make 1,500 a
month delivering pizzas shut up and go
to work and go to school gripe at me
tell me you can't go to school you live
in the real world yes I do I live in a
world where we use mathematics and
arithmetic which is something you learn
when you go to school stop this stuff
guys check out this kappahd casbah Road
future there's eight episodes on our
website borrowed future it will blow
your mind how predatory this industry is
it's out of control